high breath i mean like if you need say
you're
think about your act and you're like oh
i need some more family stuff it's like
well then you go hang out with your
family more like you know
or i need i want some mall material then
you go walk around the mall
for two days and see if you come up with
stuff and it's like to me that stuff
becomes way more relatable
than being like you know i mean you're
also trying not to write jokes that
everybody's
coming up with right like i don't like
coming up with topics that
you know you know i've been thinking
about like this chronovirus thing like
so if i shoot a special kind of after
this
all lifts up and we can go back to
perform
i you know i'll probably have a joke
about the chronoverse but it's like i
gotta do
one like that's not gonna be done like
everybody else and so you got to think
of
so you got to somehow find a way to do
it that's going to be different
uh so many people talk about the exact
same stuff so many people talk about
stuff
like i mean i had an old joke i've
brought it up before like stuff but like
on the tonight show i did a joke about
saying i like donald trump this is when
he was
in the primaries and the whole reason
for that joke
was just because everybody said they
hated him so that's
the once everybody says it's one of the
only
topical things i've done and it was
still not topical uh
but it's i just wanted to try to be like
how can i do this
that everybody's saying every comedian
says they hate him so how can i say i
like him
but without getting killed by you know
everybody because
you're saying something like that and so
you got to figure out those ways you
always just want to figure out a
different angle
you know that was an old like jay leno
thing they
like i remember reading like out of one
like the comedy bible or
judy you know one of those old books
yeah but they were saying like
jay leno like everybody had mcdonald's
joke and then someone was like what have
you seen jay leno's mcdonald's joke
and it was like because his was the best
and everybody else's was whatever
so like unless you think your joke is
the best or different enough
then you know then i don't know there's
no reason to dive into
like a topic that everybody's doing
you